hey everybody just got back from the
trail run so that means one thing
recovery so I thought I would make a
little recovery drink with you guys show
you one example of something that I
might eat when I come back from a long
run or a long ride or what happened so
what we have here today got lots of
fruits and vegetables we're going to
blend them up in the Vitamix so let's do
it
first of all we got kale one of my
favorites for you a little apple and I
got beets like I'm going to put a half a
beat in and then I'm also gonna put in
beet greens beet greens have a lot of
nutrients and most people just cut them
off and throw them away
but if you really show you can actually
pay them or eat them wrong and some
sprouts
I have a little hemp protein I like
living harvest stuff it's great so you
don't have to overdo it
the primitive that is fine and I also
have a Vegas sport protein this is a
combination of hemp pee and brown rice
protein to make sure you're getting a
complete amino acid profile you want to
get your protein bunch of different
sources so as you can see temperature
this
much longer you put it depends upon how
thick you want it obviously more water
and make it us to people but as you can
see there's a ton of stuff in here so
it's going to be coming and then just
blend it up
[Music]
let's give it a try all right
this will jack you up so enjoy thanks
for stopping by
[Music]
you